andere dame ist luca meine lieben
freunde falls jedoch kein
weihnachtsgeschenk haben sollte dann ist
das erst mal blut weil weihnachten ist
ein paar tage her allerdings kann ich
euch dann wirklich nur wärmstens diese
tolles mai die tasten da steht ja auch
schon seit ein paar jahren
wir haben uns hier heute allerdings
nicht aufgrund dieser wunderschönen
tasse versammelt meine lieben freunde
denn
ihr seht es bereits im titel meine
lieben freunde mein idol hat auf mich
reagiert und mein idol ist natürlich
selbst
nein
das nicht klug crewmitglied wird sich
jetzt wahrscheinlich fragen nur 1 09 wer
essen da ich habe vor ein zwei wochen
ein video hochgeladen in dem ich mir mal
die kanäle die immer so penetrant und
habe meinen videos in den kommentaren
werbung machen angeschaut habe und da
war ein 09 mit dabei und er hat sich so
gefreut dass ich mir seinen kanal
angeschaut habe dass er ein video
gemacht hat indem er dann auch auf
meinen kanal reagiert hat und das hat er
meine hobbys und ich reagieren auf luca
genannt ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ganz kurz
erstmal das mit dem format
das müssen wir noch mal üben ja leute
die sich gewünscht hat werde ich jetzt
hat er mich lukas genannt ja leute wie
lucas sich gewünscht hat nein damit
kannst du dich mal ein graben geben
werde ich jetzt aufzeigen video dass sie
den wenn ich jetzt sage was ich weiss
ist jetzt nicht das neueste von ihm zu
17 modell aber
[Musik]
wie schlimm hätte er gleich auf meinen
ersten bock reagieren können hat einen
guten abschluss
okay ich bin ich nicht sagen aber ich
bin der mls
[Musik]
emil ist überhaupt kein problem dass du
nicht den namen sagen möchtest emil 11
mich ärgert dass gerade dieser stelle wo
man zuletzt in dem video gesagt hat
mensch ich will euch echt nicht sagen
wie viel ich trat auf dem konto aber was
ist ein mittlerer sechsstelliger betrag
mit einer 4 vorne
[Musik]
ich will nicht sagen wie alt ich bin
aber ist es das alter zwischen 23 und 25
ja gut komplett die homies reagieren ich
bin einfach ein computer fan und ich
habe auch meine ersten kollektion so
titulieren alles schon gekauft so du
hast auch hier zugeschlagen und auch es
dann relativ neu in diesem
ja
aus der relativ neuen dingen
ich denke jetzt nicht noch mal raus und
jetzt haben wir schon mal die
möglichkeit weil jemand gefallen ist
bei denen der agent wurde bei dir ja
also jungs das video ist jetzt 20
prozent vorbei ich habe jetzt noch nicht
was hier angeguckt aber ich glaube ich
bin auch der einzige youtuber der ersten
mag wenn man direkt auf den punkt kommt
wo sexuell bei mir ist es so dass
wirklich zwischen dem beginn meiner
videos und dem richtigen beginn des
themas wovon das video handel dafür geht
ganz wenig zeit
ich will die leute kriegen drauf die
sind die anderen wünschen kommen noch 65
und ich bin jetzt ein bisschen fame
[Musik]
flott wird das ist eben forsberg
wahrscheinlich keiner von meinen
zuschauern von firmen stimmt hätte nicht
ausschneiden am anfang waren ganz cool
ist ja ja ja e mail
liebe grüße viel erfolg im nächsten
spiel für leib zwischen der inneren oft
würmer co ja ganz liebe grüße vielleicht
eher ein großer fan
so hast du die taste ich glaub's mich
habe ich die ich habe ich trink nicht
[Musik]
das war einfach ein komplettes pay klar
vor den beiden jungs wollen sich jetzt
bestimmt bei mir einschleimen ich finde
es klasse dass das video einfach vier
minuten geht ich habe gedacht dass man
ist viel schneller sagt ja
tja rein
kann sowas mainformat das video endet
wenn es ja auch dafür bekannt dass die
videos immer ein bisschen länger gehen
jeder von euch einen platz zum wohnen
suchen die brücke da vorne und videos
vom zehnjährigen an die sich dann nur um
sein wie du angucken wo er in any
mittwoch singen dass spielerisches wort
sagen darf
da schon nummer von einem psychologen
[Gelächter]
ich fühle mich gerade bisschen unwohl
hier entschuldigung wir bauen hier
gerade ein service
wo sind eigentlich die anderen homies im
titel steht ja meiner hobbys und ich
reagieren auf luca oder sie es nicht
gelistet
der sonntag genommen dort bewertung
nicht bescheuert
ja
[Musik]
die jungs macht euer ding da wie lachten
die lagen wir jetzt unser zelt ihrig
hätte ich gern sonnen sondern auch
maske und zum junioren maske damit ich
dann nichts mehr hören nichts mehr sehe
immer der letzte baum da auch dass kuba
danke danke des empire state building
der bigband der eiffelturm das
brandenburger tor dass das ist waldmanns
kunst danke ich finde es auch jetzt
krass dass ich mir das hier alles
anzugucken so lange ausgehalten habe
[Musik]
für euch hoffe es hat euch gefallen mir
die us-regierung mit diesem kanal und
aktive die kirche um kein video mehr zu
verpassen so gemacht an der stelle das
häufig wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde mir wurde
dieses video hier zahlreichen zugesandt
und alle leute meinten was unten auf 1
09 reagiert der hat jetzt auf dich
reagiert also guck dir das mal an habe
ich jetzt getan wenn es euch gefallen
hat das kind einen daumen hoch und ein
video der abonniert main kanal der
großteil der leute die sich dieses video
gerade angucken sind nicht abonnent von
meinem kanal ihr habt echt eigentlich
eine ziemlich gute entscheidung
getroffen
[Musik]